[Music]
every one of the six clubs has faced a
rebellion
and at anfield the defiance is
unequivocal
but at the park pub opposite the cop
this is about as close as you get
to support for the breakaway you can't
afford to get left behind if it goes off
and you're not on the bus where are you
tell me whatever the rules the next
thing that will happen
is a set of home games will get played
in dubai
then they'll get played in singapore
then they'll get played in new york
they won't be played here so
but would you still watch it no
their rivals everton have big ambitions
of their own but are not part of this
project
inequality here is stark dave runs the
food banks
set up by fans for the people around
them yesterday afternoon we were out
there distributing
40 000 eggs um
and two pallet loads of bread and the
billions of pounds
that flows into football clubs it
doesn't ripple down into local
communities
and that's why every football club in
this country is irrespective of what
brandon they put on the path and fabric
of the community
the ability to dream is a fundamental
part of football
and it exists in every club in the land
however fanciful that dream is that a
club like trammer rovers could rise to
challenge
with the very very best but under this
model
that dream is effectively killed off
like every other club they're desperate
to get real fans back in
trauma's executive chairman was once the
boss
at the fa you know liverpool fans and
everton fans in this area
and trauma fans have been going to work
on the monday morning with the bragging
rights
well you won't be playing everton and as
a consequence you know you can see
the paucity of the experience that those
fans will have compared to what's been
enjoyed
you know for the last hundred and twenty
hundred and thirty 40 years
liverpool's american owners have
previously performed a u-turn
when fans protested about rising ticket
prices
but this storm is bigger than anything
that's gone before
tom parmenter sky news merseyside